it puts really incredible pressure
on the defense good defense there again
from solomon hill made it a tough shot
but then they turn it over james with
the steal throws it up
davis back up and this time able to
finish you know the dodgers started in
brooklyn
why are you hating on locations i'm not
hating i'm saying it's not the same
organization
caruso throws it down i'm eric spoelstra
if we're gonna lose let's lose 40.
but i mean let it be pat riley
had the memorial day massacre
and
[Applause]
butler gets in the paint blocked by
howard picked up by danny green
green back to james james charges down a
lane goes inside and
easily lays it up and in well you're
right
he's always been an outstanding
olynyk passing side stolen by danny
green
james left open has plenty of time and
knocks down the three he's only missed
one shot
ball poked away james picks it up
[Applause]
james down elaine runs into robinson
count it and the foul
duncan robinson finds hiro hiro off the
bounce
deflected and stolen here's lebron james
going down the lane draws the foul count
it and one
seems game by game with a change in the
way team's playing now
that's not the lakers brand of
basketball they were helped by the
block by lebron the zone defense of the
miami heat lebron james gets beat
by hero but the extra effort
measures the basketball and then blocks
it without foul
what a great actor
james pass that's the 10th turnover
for the lakers 10 in the first quarter
we still have 243 remaining
we'll get into a skirmish with morrison
hero right now
great job by lebron again force him into
a tough fadeaway
give yourself a chance jimmy butler pass
stolen by davis
anticipated that beautifully caruso
drives down elaine left-handed won't go
davis on the follow rondo
[Music]
and rondo pleading the case as we see
the
great put back by anthony davis double
team takes a tough shot
won't go bam out of bio skies for the
rebound but stolen by rondo feet inside
to danny green
heads up play from rajon rondo and the
lakers back up by two until he starts
taking and making and i think if you're
in miami you don't overreact
you got to give that shot up and good
defense by the lakers off the turnover
danny green throws it down butler tried
to
distract him a bit easy one by flicking
it from behind
james leads him and green dunks it home
[Applause]
butler makes his drive goes inside
blocked by davis
caldwell pope picks it up davis has it
again
butler turns the corner the ability to
recover
[Applause]
adebayo pass inside through behind
robinson
james floats it up and anthony davis
with the one-handed tomahawk
and a half remaining here in the first
butler change of direction blocked by
davis picked up by rondo
throws it ahead to kuzma kuzma gathers
goes inside and lays it in
seven on the 24. butler drives tiptoes
along the baseline pass deflected
[Applause]
another turnover from miami rondo to
davis davis inside
kyle kuzma banks at home where the
lakers are at their best
the turnover and then the decision
making
rondo davis and james
that's lebron james first turnover
butler pass inside
stolen by caldwell pope
[Applause]
james finds contavious caldwell pope
knocks down the three-pointer
points off the bench but into the hands
it goes to butler shot clock at four
three-pointer shot blocked davis his
third block of the game
james to danny green gets a good look
danny green with a big three-pointer
green fakes goes to the side
three-pointer
butler pushing the other end butler out
of control
and james picks it up throws it ahead
caldwell pulp goes up and throws it down
how much do we want to try to get
anthony davis going
versus get our best player
involved in as many plays as possible
lebron james good defense there from
davis
forces the turnover and james with the
flush down the other end
ray reed doesn't have the shooting on
the floor as miami shrinks defensively
but a tremendous cut
and fine toronto bad pass from hiro
caldwell pope the steel drives down the
other end and lays it up and in
kendrick gets down the lane blocked by
davis
saved by caruso
what a defensive sequence by anthony
davis
caldwell pope draws the foul banks at
home many times we've seen this
in the last couple of months his ability
they have nothing in there
they need more skill and shooting on the
floor caruso with the steal caruso got
the start doesn't have big numbers
as james drives gets inside leia banks
at home and a foul